Gregory first of all I have to ask you
did everybody that was on three and a
half take you out for dinner last night
get you ready give you a nice massage
for today's game analyze absolutely
everything during the night what was uh
what was the feeling
um no it was just a normal game for me I
mean I prepared you know like it is a
normal game
um first of all I'm not very good
playing Under Pressure plus uh there
shouldn't be any pressure because medic
is so much ahead that you know even if I
win this game
yeah yeah yeah yeah very very slim
um however you know I prepared a lot and
my preparation was successful I got very
good Advantage after the opening and you
were blitzing up to this move when I
tweet too yeah right here right here uh
I knew that the move is Bishop G2
but during the game
um I thought that maybe Knight G3 is
even better so try to go for E4 yeah
that was any four so so Knight G3 is
basically over the board of inspiration
by the way it has been played by some
very strong players oh okay okay I
didn't know yeah yeah it's definitely a
good move okay H4 E6 and now E4
and A5
okay G6
I think it was
how did you assess because we are trying
to assess this position as well we
weren't really sure I was optimistic but
uh cautiously optimistic so so because
obviously there are problems with my
Pawn structure right so
he also has problems with the pawn
structure he has two weak pawns before
A6 right D5 as well
and uh
uh so it's double edged basically but uh
I should be better with with the bishop
pair with his king is not very
comfortable yeah uh but I knew I need to
be precise and I spent quite a bit of
time here but I just didn't find uh the
way to go originally let's go back
originally my plan was just one move
back white right Knight G7 you know 95
97 originally my plan was to play Knight
H6
uh but then Rook H6 Bishop H6 Knight F5
and I didn't like my position I thought
black has very good compensation for the
exchange yeah no more attack yeah right
right right
so uh 93 I also looked at uh but there
was something about 93
uh I think he's gonna play Knight of
fate and again I thought his position is
like super solid those Knights protect
the king so well and uh yeah and so I
not easy to create anything against his
weaknesses right right right I I didn't
really want to make a draw I I wanted to
play for a win but I just didn't see uh
any way to make life difficult for him I
I feel like if I
would continue playing I can lose but I
I don't see how I can win this uh
strategically easy to go wrong right
right you need bhp5 F4 F5 somehow but it
just is not happening right right you
could ask a weaknesses on before an A6
and theoretically in abstract way if I
trade queens and go into some kind of
end game those weaknesses could tell but
uh just couldn't figure out how to do it
so
uh Gregory I need to ask you about this
position because we're looking at it
right now it seems to have simplified a
little bit simplified a little bit but
it was so crazy
out of the opening this was the position
I mean we didn't understand anything
have you seen this in your preparation
what is the opening
it's some sort of uh they they played in
in a different room so
yeah so I I didn't even see it's a
sicilian right some crazy the
this line uh eager plays this line his
whole life as black they played it last
year as well oh okay so it's some sort
of a battle uh going on here
theoretical battle right right I think
in this position
after a page three he played 95
last year now he decided to go for
Knight P6 and uh this is what we have
right now what are you looking at their
game at all were you worried about no
they play in different rooms they didn't
go there yeah yeah I didn't see I was
much more concentrated on the game
because Karissa and Alice okay yes
because it was very interesting because
I'm sure uh I was quickly played
nightshades G4
um Carissa went into thinking and so it
was it was some crazy preparation from
Alice and a good response by Carissa by
the way so great game that one as well
Gregory thank you very much for joining
us and still a couple of rounds to go
still plenty to fight for yeah we'll try
to let you go get some rest thank you
very much a quick question for you
Gregory uh you played in the game the
two Bishops uh you you you opened the
position Bishop E2 and Bishop F4 and you
you played to open the position trading
on D5 subsequently but you had an
interesting option of shutting the game
down E5 I'm assuming Knight G8 C5 I'm
assuming Bishop takes H4 and Rook B4 so
in one hand you trade off the H4 Pawn
for the B4 Pawn was this a consideration
did you pay attention to this during the
game I was optimistic that you were
going to play like this and I thought
this was going to be creating a very
intriguing imbalance
uh to be honest I I didn't look at this
I I didn't I didn't want to force
anything
uh and uh I felt like uh I don't want to
close the position if if I would want to
close the position
then I probably wouldn't play Knight G3
then even earlier yeah I I would play
just you know E5 earlier but uh yeah I
was looking for a completely different
type of the game so exactly that's why
it didn't enter my mind all right well
Gregory good luck in the remaining games
uh very very nice as uh for Malik said
what a wonderful result uh drawing with
the black pieces and let's take a look
at the results